let's keep doing some Laplace transforms
and one it's good to see where a lot of
those Laplace transform tables you'll
see later on actually come from and it
just makes you comfortable with the
mathematics which is really just kind of
your second semester calculus
mathematics but it makes you comfortable
with the whole notion of what we're
doing so first of all let me just
rewrite the definition of the Laplace
transform so it's the L from Laverne and
Shirley so the plus transform of some
function of T is equal to the improper
integral from zero to infinity of e to
the minus st times our function times
our function of t and so it's respect to
DT so let's do another Laplace transform
let's say that we want to take the
Laplace transform let's say we want to
take the Laplace transform and now our
function f of T let's say it is e to the
a T Laplace transform of e to the a T
well we just substituted it into this
definition of the Laplace transform so
that is equal to and this is all going
to be really good integration practice
for us especially integration by parts
almost every Laplace transform problem
turns into an integration by parts
problem which as we learned long ago
integration by parts is just the reverse
product rule so anyway this is equal to
the integral from 0 to infinity e to the
minus st e to the minus s T times e to
the a T all right that's our F of T DT
well this is equal to just adding the
exponents because we have the same base
unit role from 0 to infinity of e to the
what a minus s e to the
a-minus s T DT and what's the
antiderivative of this well that's equal
to that is equal to what with respect to
T so we're at it's equal to 1 1 over a
minus that's that's just going to be a
constant right so we can just leave it
out on the outside 1 over a minus s
times e to the e to the a minus s T and
we're going to evaluate that from T is
equal to infinity or the limit as T
approaches infinity to T is equal to 0
and I just I could have put this inside
the brackets but it's just a constant
term right a neither none of them have
T's in them so I can just pull them out
and so this is equal to 1 over a minus s
times now what is the limit you know we
essentially have to evaluate T as at
infinity so what is the the limit at
infinity well we have two cases here
right if this exponent if this exponent
if this a minus S is a positive number
if a minus s is greater than 0 what's
going to happen well as we approach
infinity e to the Infinity just gets
bigger and bigger and bigger right
because it's e to an infinitely positive
exponent so it actually it we don't get
an answer and when you do improper
integrals when you take the limit to
infinity and it doesn't come to a finite
number does the limit doesn't approach
anything that means that the limit or
actually the improper integral diverges
and so there is no limit no limit and to
some degree we can say that the Laplace
transform is not defined when a minus s
is greater than 0 or when a is greater
than s now what happens if a minus s is
less than 0 so if a minus s is less than
0 well then this
this is going to be some negative number
here right and then if we take e to an
infinitely negative number well then
that does approach something that
approaches zero and we did we saw that
in the previous in the previous video
and I hope you understand what I'm
saying right e to an infinitely negative
number is zero or it approaches zero
while e to an infinitely positive number
is just infinity so it doesn't really
converge on anything so anyway so if I
assume that a minus s is less than zero
or a is less than s and this is the
assumption I will make just so that I
get so that this integral this improper
integral actually converges to something
so if a minus s is less than zero and
this is a negative number e to the a
minus s times Well T where T approaches
infinity will be zero minus this
integral evaluated at zero so when you
evaluate this at zero what happens T
equals zero this whole thing becomes 0 e
to the 0 is 1 e to the 0 is 1 and we are
left with what minus 1 over a minus s
and that's just the same thing as 1 over
s minus a so we have our next entry in
our Laplace transform table we have our
next entry and that is the Laplace
transform the Laplace transform of e to
the a e to the a T is equal to 1 over s
minus a as long as we make the
assumption that s is greater than a this
is true what s is greater than a or a is
less than s either way you can view it
either way so that's our second entry in
a non Laplace transform table
fascinating and actually let's relate
this to our our previous entry in our
Laplace transform table right what was
our what was our first entry in our
Laplace transform table
it was Laplace transform of 1 is equal
to 1 over s right
well is it one just the same thing as e
to the zero so we could have said that
this is the Laplace I know I'm running
out of space but I'll do it here in
purple we could have said Laplace
transform of one is the same thing as e
to the 0 times T right and that equals 1
over s and luckily it's good to see that
that is consistent and actually remember
we even made the condition when s is
greater than zero right we assume that s
is greater than zero in this example and
lo and behold if you then here again you
say S is greater than zero
this is completely consistent with this
one right because if a is equal to zero
then the Laplace transform of e to the 0
is just 1 over s minus 0 that's just 1
over s and we have to assume that s is
greater than 0 so really these are kind
of the same entry in our Laplace
transform table but it's always nice in
mathematics when we see that two results
we got trying to do slightly different
problems actually are in some ways
connected or the same result anyway I'll
see you in the next video and we'll keep
trying to build our table of Laplace
transforms and maybe three or four
videos from now I'll actually show you
how these transforms are extremely
useful in solving all sorts of
differential equations
see you soon